eu queria contar para vocês quem eu sou
ou quem costumava ser
eu nasci dia 27 de março de 83 com dois
irmãos 18 anos mais velho que o outro
com 10 anos a mais
meus pais eram de minas gerais então se
tem alguém de minas aqui já me abençoe
eu nasci em florianópolis onde eu quero
ficar e de lá só me mudo para brasília
já o espírito porque eu sempre fui
corajosa bem cara de pau e espaçosa com
a autoconfiança que sobrava imagina dois
irmãos minha mãe sonhava em ter uma
menina e oito anos depois
então eu fui muito acarinhado muito
amada muito querida muito desejada
então desde nova eu me envolvi em tudo
que eu dançava eu era esportista eu
corri com a tocha olímpica no colégio eu
é do diretório acadêmico eu fui líder de
classe e tudo onde havia liderança eu
queria está me perguntar assim que você
quer ser quando crescer eu tinha a
resposta na ponta da língua
o presidente da república é com o centro
da minha alma existisse com clareza um
poder e uma inspiração e uma força para
transformar um país inteiro
e aí saindo da faculdade onde
desenvolveu o projeto de diretório
acadêmico onde eu abrir a primeira
empresa junho daquela instituição
eu fui pro mundo abrir a minha própria
empresa e quando cheguei na agência de
publicidade eu disse
o símbolo do negócio vai ser uma alça
então faça um site inteiro de um sim e
eles disseram mas vanessa isso é é
contra o teu mercado vai fazer coaching
safar de alto desenvolvimento pretende
colocar a fotografia de pessoas de terno
pessoas sentadas em uma mesa de reuniões
com o notebook e mãos dadas
eu disse mas não é quem eu sou e eu fui
firme disse faça tudo de onça porque é
incoerente que o cliente chegue até mim
encontre
algo que ele não verá se ele vai ver no
site uma coisa e quando me encontrar for
outra fã vai existir uma coisa lhe que
não vai gerar a tal da empatia tão
necessária para que esses negócios
aconteceram porque life coaching que é o
amor da minha vida e eu tive que ser
firme eles contestaram eu falei não essa
é a minha natureza ea natureza é
perfeita e eu preciso representá-la no
meu negócio e essa é a vanessa que eu
sempre fui até o que me aconteceu em
agosto de 2013 quando eu abrir um
negócio e 2010
em maio eu estava com essa roupa e
quando eu escolhi essa roupa pra vir
hoje eu disse eu sempre me deu sorte
essa roupa e é clássica ela tem a ver
comigo
tem uma parte de mim que ainda se
comunica com essa onça que representa
parte da minha natureza
mas em agosto de 2013
o irmão mais velho faleceu e parte da
minha natureza tudo ficou naquele dia eu
entendi isso hoje
só que essa morte
ela foi absolutamente necessária para
que eu entendesse que havia outras
pessoas que viviam a mesma dor e se tem
uma coisa que a natureza sempre teve foi
uma paixão louca por crise
quem gosta de crise
adoro uma crise então aqui sabe quando
tem uma complexidade eu gosto de saber
do diagnóstico eu amo e amava empatia e
precisava amadurecer esse traço e indo
estudar minha própria crise que foi o
que eu sempre fiz eu desenvolvi um
gráfico que me fez compreender porque eu
tinha me tornado essa pessoa que está
aqui hoje
o gráfico haeuser modernidade trouxe um
flip chart para nós
o gráfico ele diz o seguinte nós somos o
resultado do que nasce com a gente e eu
sempre chamo de x
toda aquela situação que não foi tão bem
resolvida nos nossos antepassados as
histórias que a gente carrega pai mãe
avós porque eles nasceram o que fizeram
como morreram como trabalharam isso já
nasce com a gente eu sou resultado diz
que nasce comigo
somado a isso tem todos os hábitos
positivos e não tão felizes da minha
família então se hoje por exemplo eu não
medito como todo mundo é bom pra você
medite eu não faço uma oração antes de
me alimentar é porque minha família não
fazia isso porque se estivesse na minha
rotina eu seria o resultado disso seria
assim
então é só resultado do que nasce comigo
dos hábitos da minha família e dos
grandes eventos da minha história como
concorrer com a tocha olímpica como ter
perdido um irmão
acontece que dependendo da força do
evento
a gente perde um pedaço da nossa
natureza e surge na nossa vida uma linha
tracejada nesse x de agosto de 2013
existia uma vanessa que era uma onça
como é muito corajosa presidente da
república e depois dessa linha tracejada
ela continuou sua esforçada
eu sou dedicada eu gosto das crises eu
amo gente e ainda acredito nos meus
sonhos mas esse coraçãozinho aqui ficou
antes da linha tracejada e quando essa
linha tracejada passa a existir na nossa
vida
ela cria um para uma linha paralela ou
seja uma linha distante da nossa própria
natureza que essa aqui ea gente se desde
identifica a gente pensa
a vida não tem mais sentido já não sou
mais a mesma pessoa ea gente se perde
engraçado que eu fui conversar com a
pessoa que está em depressão e o
trabalho eu comecei esse trabalho em
2008 e abrir empresa em 2
10 e uma pessoa veio conversar comigo
dizendo eu tenho depressão eu quero
desistir da minha vida e no último ano o
número de pessoas que vieram até nós
dizendo estou com crises de ansiedade
depressão crise de pânico e quero
desistir da minha vida imenso é muito
muito grande mesmo e eu achei só uma
frase que conectava todas essas pessoas
que a vida tinha perdido o sentido e eu
me identifiquei e eu comecei a pesquisar
nessa crise
quando eu recebi o convite protex eu
queria trazer alguma coisa que eu nunca
tivesse dito e que representasse a minha
própria cura e eu organizei em três sets
o que foi uma coincidência não foi
intencional que o resgate da nossa
própria natureza se dará se eu tiver a
capacidade de visitar esses três s
um chamado sugestão oeste chamado
sentido e um é chamado segredo
em 2010 eu tinha um namorado porque era
muito apaixonada e esse namorado
terminou comigo no feriado de 7 de
setembro
eu pensei que ia para festas em mim
porque foi muito dolorido naquela época
porque eu gostava dele não queria
terminar
passado um tempo depois de muito
sofrimento ele quis que a gente voltasse
em uma churrascada na minha família lá
em casa é cheguei pro meu pai disse
aí eu queria um conselho eu queria uma
sugestão sua volta ou não volta pra ele
e ele me disse vanessa
não quero compartilhar comigo essa
decisão porque quem vai acordar do lado
dele todos os dias é você não eu queria
que ele trabalhasse o meu caminho com o
meu pai eu entendi algo fundamental
sobre a busca da minha natureza
ninguém jamais ter a capacidade de dizer
pra mim o que é melhor o que é pior pra
minha história
só eu e quando alguém me sugere essa
pessoa assina um termo de
responsabilidade que nem sempre ser
acolhido quando eu estiver sofrendo com
aquela opinião
e para buscar a nossa natureza é preciso
que a gente encontre pessoas que façam
boas perguntas para que amplie a minha
consciência boas perguntas me ajudem a
pensar porque eu sei o que eu quero da
vida não precisa de sugestão nós sabemos
a nossa natureza se conhece
ela só precisa ser escutada e com isso
eu preciso fazer e por isso eu preciso
fazer boas perguntas para encontrar
minha natureza tem uma coisa incrível
aqui que eu sempre gostei muito da
palavra empatia e e quando eu descobri o
conceito da compaixão eu me encantei
porque a empatia ela pressupõe uma
condição de sofrimento compartilhado na
em que se eu sinto uma dor e você também
nós compartilhamos aquela dor mas duas
pessoas com dor e eventualmente não
consegue encontrar a sua cura é preciso
alguém curado tá então compartilhar
aquela luz a compaixão ela é a condição
de acreditar que o outro reúne os
recursos necessários para realizar
qualquer coisa e na hora em que eu
sugiro eu corto o caminho que aquele ser
precisa desenvolver para merecer a sua
auto estima ea sua autoconfiança faz
sentido quando eu falo de sentido pra
mim é o mais forte eu comentei que eu
conversei com aquela moça e ela disse eu
perdi o sentido como todos os outros
disseram e eu também perdi o meu e eu
entendi finalmente aquela frase
significava porque a gente pensa aí a
gente que trabalha com coaching e fala
de metas né
que sentido é meta sentido é um sonho é
uma orientação e na hora em que eu
conversava com essa moça eu peguei na
mão dela e eu disse
tive um insight sentido é toc não
acredito como é simples porque a gente
sofisticada solução quando na verdade o
sentido está na base de toda vez que
quiser a olhar para um problema nosso e
sofisticar em corra a solução sempre
será simples
eu entendi com o luto do júnior foi que
para que o resgatasse sentido eu
precisava dos meus pais e precisava
honrar a minha história com eles mesmo
que meu pai eventualmente tivesse
abandonado um evento que eu tivesse
participado ou não tivesse sido a minha
mãe o meu irmão sou meus amigos
as melhores histórias ou melhores
escolhas que eu tive eu preciso aprender
sobre a minha história qualquer problema
vem da base eu preciso voltar pra ela
pra encontrar sentido eu preciso dos
meus pais e dos meus amigos de infância
eu preciso de um amor que me compreenda
e eu preciso estar com aqueles que
compartilham comigo a mesma dor para que
o resgate sentido mas o que eu entendi
hoje mas com muita profundidade é que
pra falar da minha própria natureza para
encontrar sentido eu tenho que me
encostar
eu tenho que me tocar eu tenho que
trazer um vestido de um sangue novo para
o palco e estará acompanhada da minha
natureza fazendo o meu auto resgate e
permitindo me tocar me encostar
recuperar os meus sentidos a pele a
visão o paladar busca de sentido que a
gente não queira atalhar o caminho do
outro é encostar se eu tenho certeza que
eu vim fazer isso aqui hoje mesmo e por
fim é o segredo é é uma confissão eu vou
fazer
da primeira vez eu estava na 8ª série
professor de religião pediu pra que a
gente fizesse um trabalho e eu não
estava a fim de fazer o trabalho de
religião olha que pecado e eu não fiz um
trabalho forte na época o trabalho de
papel almaço não era computador então
não tinha como esqueci de imprimir não
era nada disso não existe essa
tecnologia e no dia de entregar o fim já
que entreguei e quando ele foi
desenvolver os trabalhos ele falou
vanessa você não fez seu trabalho e diz
que isso professor claro que eu fiz se
eu perder o trabalho ele não você não
entregou foi entregue
com certeza eu fui firme na minha
mentira até hoje 20 anos já se passaram
e eu faço votos de que esse vídeo chegue
nele porque eu possa dizer professor
desculpa eu menti
como pode alguém querer ser presidente
da república
sem uma revisita os seus valores e aos
seus princípios que vêm desde a base
se eu não for capaz de acessar os meus
segredos do tipo uma vez que nas lojas
americanas com a minha mãe tinha 89 anos
existia naquela época um acesso às balas
e aí eu dizia mãe já volto e até onde as
balas ficavam na bomboniere pegava uma
seap no bolso e não pagava por aquilo
muito do que a gente precisa enfrentar
são os nossos segredos as nossas
tradições os nossos roubos às nossas
mentiras a porta para o futuro está na
chave presa no passado e muitas vezes
essa chave precisa ser uma confissão
como a que eu escolhi fazer hoje porque
eu não sinto que o presidente da
república precisa fazer tudo certo tempo
inteiro e será algo além de humano mas
precisa antes de tudo ter coragem de
enfrentar os seus segredos e confessar
os seus erros
é disso que nós estamos carentes o meu
irmão ele era muito sábio e ele dizia
vanessa o micro se reproduz no macro
como você pendura sua roupa no varal
você faz tudo na vida
por isso a importância de revisitar
mesmo pequeno segredo como uma balinha
das lojas americanas uma mentira
inocente professor de religião
se eu não revisita os meus princípios os
meus valores
eu não consigo e candidatar à
presidência da república por sentir que
não mereço o maior sucesso que eu
poderia faz sentido eu quero dizer mais
uma frase do júnior já que hoje
certamente o que me abençoou aqui é ele
e hoje de manhã eu acordei eu trouxe uma
bolsa nada a ver
nada a ver com calma verde não combinava
com nada que eu trouxe e na hora que eu
fui mexer na bolsa encontrei essa
gargantilha eo juninho tinha como
símbolo número 8 ele casou de 88 a 88 de
8 de abril 8 de agosto de 2010 10 888
era o símbolo do infinito dele
ele dizia vanessa então assim é hoje
houveram muitos sinais da presença deles
foi só um dos vários que apareceram que
me emocionaram
quanto mais iluminada uma pessoa é mais
escuridão ela atrai não pra que ela se
torne escuridão também mas para que ela
saiba que encontrara indo a
responsabilidade da lucidez ela em khost
outra vela apagada ea ilumine que a
gente possa enfrentar a nossa sugestão o
nosso sentido o nosso segredo no sentido
de resgatar o merecimento de viver de
acordo com a nossa natureza
eu quero dedicar esse momento ao júnior
e aos meus ancestrais que acompanham ele
mandar um recado para onde quer que ele
esteja de que talvez eu me candidate
mesmo porque o mundo precisa do meu
melhor
eu não vou desistir diante dos meus
jogos e diante das batalhas que aparecem
porque melhor é muito legal eu quero
agradecer ao meu pai e minha mãe que me
deram oportunidade da vida ao juliano
que é meu outro irmão que está vivo e
que é meu sócio no negócio aos meus
sobrinhos a lígia lúcia meus cunhados a
minha equipe extraordinária hoje nós
estamos atendendo clientes em 24 estados
do brasil em 12 países
nós temos um instituto que já esteve em
25 escolas de santa catarina e do paraná
quero agradecer à equipe do tex e dá os
parabéns pelo excepcional evento
me sinto absolutamente honrada em
participar especialmente porque
representa o meu coração que eu vi em
resgatar e torcer imensamente para que a
minha luz tenha encostado alguma vela
apagada
mas dizer essencialmente que hoje o que
estava apagado em mim
certamente foi iluminado por vocês muito
obrigado
[Aplausos]